well welcome back to PB on censored live
from New York City I'm joined now by the
former New Jersey governor and
Republican presidential candidate Chris
Christie Governor Christie great to have
you back on the program uh I wonder if
you could just start by giving me your
reaction to the fact that a 100
journalists were taken into a room and
played unedited raw footage of these
Terror attacks on October the 7th
because so many people fueled by social
media are simply refusing to accept what
happened
happened look Piers I think it's a
testimony as to what I've been talking
about for the past few weeks the rise of
anti-Semitism both here in the United
States and around the world is palpable
it's been palpable for some time and
it's increasing and we need to be
speaking out against that uh there is no
other reason um to be uh needing to show
this video except for people's disbelief
based upon anti-semitic views and
anti-semitic propaganda that has been
put out there not only across social
media but being put out in many of
America's colleges and universities uh
and this is disgraceful uh and it is
dangerous I mean it's this to me Beyond
doubt that what happened on October the
7th was one of the most horrendous
Terror attacks of Modern Times And if
you can't bring yourself to express
outrage over it there's something wrong
with you um but the question now is what
is a proportionate response by Israel
and I'm not sure what the answer to that
is other than already within two weeks
nearly three four times as many
Palestinian mainly civilians have lost
their lives in retaliation strikes by
Israel that number is likely to
massively increase if there is a ground
invasion is this proportionate do you
think look Pierce I think the Israeli
Defense Forces and their government
should have three priorities here
priority number one is a a retaliatory
response against um Hamas that severely
degrades if not eliminates their
capability um of of striking against
Israel again number two should be
getting the hostages out as many of you
as them as you can um both American and
Israeli hostages that are being held Now
by Hamas Hamas and then third is to try
to have the response be seen as
something
by the rest of the world as setting the
stage for conversations with the rest of
the Arab world about how this type of
conduct doesn't create a peaceful
situation in facts in fact causes great
great um harm to everyone in the region
and begin those talks again and I think
those should be the three priorities an
appropriate retaliation the return of
the hostages and setting the stage for
the next round of conversations with
with Arab countries who don't want to
see this type of violence perpetrated
against anyone in the mid East again I
mean there are a lot of experts uh who
have long memories from Iraq and
Afghanistan uh the response of course
mainly by the United States with with
the British and others uh to the terror
attacks on 911 who believe that if we
don't learn the lessons from what
happened there 20 years of Mayhem pretty
much coming out of our response that if
Israel does go in with a full blown
ground Invasion uh then it could lead to
a far more serious situation than even
the one we have in front of us
now well Piers look Israel has an
absolute right to protect both its
safety and its territorial integrity and
the only way to protect that safety and
territorial Integrity is to degrade the
capability of Hamas to do what they did
on October 7th again and the Israeli
Defense Force forces are going to have
to make the judgment about what type of
ground force is necessary to protect the
safety and territorial Integrity of
Israel but that's got to be their goal
and Mission nothing more nothing
less you're running for president uh
Donald Trump is still the front runner
uh many people think extraordinarily
given he's facing near 100 criminal
charges um there's no doubt if you look
at Trump's record on as president his
first term as somebody pointed out today
I think on social media Iran was hemmed
in by sanctions uh China by a trade War
Russia hadn't invaded Ukraine
Afghanistan hadn't Fallen to the Taliban
um now you see a lot of
turmoil um Trump never went to war
anywhere were we a more peaceful world
with Donald Trump as president of the
United States than we are
now well Pierce I think that's an a
super official analysis of the situation
I mean the fact is that he said he was
pulling out of Afghanistan and that if
he had gotten a second term that's
exactly what he would have done um
secondly um he set up the circumstances
to give Russia the green light to go
into Ukraine in two ways one by his con
constant public coddling and kissing of
Vladimir Putin and two um by not giving
the ukrainians the weapons they needed
and in fact for a period of time
blackmailing the Ukrainian government
and president zinski in return for
getting dirt on Joe Biden for his
reelection campaign that hardly set the
type of posture that would make the
Russians think they should not be going
in there and as far as China's concerned
his quote unquote trade War this is a
guy who said he got the greatest trade
agreements ever with China and meantime
just in the agricultural space China
hasn't uh you know uh done 25% um of
what they said they would do and
committed to in those trade Wars so the
idea that when he calls president X
brilliant and straight out of Central
Casting that that somehow deterred the
Chinese I think is a joke he also called
Hezbollah very smart what was your
response to
that that he's very
stupid and selfish and not only did he
call Hezbollah smart but he also then
went and gave a broadsided attack
against prime minister Netanyahu while
he's in the midst of defending his
country in an existential conflict with
Hamas and he did it because uh Netanyahu
had the temerity to be sane and called
Joe Biden when it was clear that he had
been legally elected the president of
the United States and that's something
that Trump will never forgive and so
what he does is rewrite history um uh
about the solomani uh uh operation and
other things because in the end all
Donald Trump cares about is that you say
he actually won the election in 2020 and
if you didn't say that or you took
actions that contradicted that then
you're his enemy so now he's attacking
Netanyahu in the midst of a war he's
calling Hezbollah very smart it's
because he's very stupid and
childish I want to play you Governor
this is a clip of uh Benjamin Netanyahu
from an interview I did with him a few
months ago before all this happened in
which we talked specifically actually at
one stage about this concept of
Collective punishment let's take a look
there have been 88 Palestinians and 15
Israelis killed so far this year it's
the highest rate of deaths in two
decades many are saying that a lot of
this is down to incend rhetoric from
some of your right-wing uh members of
your government and they particularly uh
cite uh bezel smotrich in any case uh
they're part of my government but
they're part of my government and I uh I
decide policy that you distance yourself
from comments like that uh there are
many comments would he call for the
Palestinian town of aara to be wiped out
of course not of course I that's totally
unacceptable we don't believe in
Collective punishment I go after the
terrorists I go after those who support
the terrorists but I don't believe in
Collective
punishment now many people think what
we're seeing now Governor Christie is uh
Collective punishment that thousands of
completely innocent Palestinians are
getting killed as Israel tries to go
after Hamas who of course embed El
amongst the civilian population like I
said earlier that number is only going
to increase exponentially if there's a
ground Invasion it's hard to see this as
anything other than an attack on
Palestinians in general because you
can't be selective can you in the way
that is being currently implemented by
Israel well the people who who say that
peers um I think believe that Hamas
should be rewarded for being
sneaky ra hamash should be rewarded for
doing a sneak attack on Israel killing
1,400 civilians and then going back and
hiding themselves among civilians and
thinking that by using them as human
Shields they're going to prevent Israel
from taking any retaliation I'm sorry I
don't agree with that um I think Israel
has to take the retaliation and if
Hamas decides to embed themselves with
civilians then those civilians complaint
is against the government they elected
not against the state of
Israel should Benjamin Netanyahu stay as
prime minister notwithstanding there's a
war now the vast majority of Israelis in
the polls I've seen think he is
responsible for what happened he always
said that protecting Israel and
defending Israel was his number one
priority this has been the biggest
failure of Israeli defense that uh we've
seen in modern times should he remain in
office uh look that's up to the Israeli
Parliament um and and what they do in
terms of a vote of confidence or no
confidence in their government but I
would say this that I think it's very
very dangerous to be changing
governments in the midst of an
existential War there's going to be
plenty of time peers um for there to be
an after action report about why Israeli
intelligence and other intelligence
agencies failed if they did and clearly
it seems they did to detect what Hamas
was planning and how they were going to
execute it um and it may be that prime
minister Netanyahu has to pay a
political price for that failure but I
don't think the time to do it is now
Israel is facing a a threat to their
very existence to their territorial
Integrity that needs to be dealt with
first and any political issues that uh
prime minister Netanyahu has to deal
with because of failings that may have
occurred on his watch well then he can
deal with those after this problem is
put
down Governor Chris Christie always
great to have you on the program thank
you very much
indeed